aujourd'hui un blog légèrement différent
puisque je vais parler du matériel que
j'utilise pour mon blog un blog un petit
peu plus technique où je vais vous
présenter les différentes caméras les
micros et tout ce que j'utilise pour
faire mon blog si ça ne t'intéresse pas
tu peux directement ap et revenir demain
pour voir le blog suivre si ça
t'intéresse tu peux rester et je vais
présenter une caméra qui est
extraordinaire est ce que tu es prêt
c'est parti pour filmer au début je
pensais utiliser ça elles n'ont pas ça
pas ça non plus voilà ça je pensais
utiliser ça un iphone ou tout ce qu'il
ya de plus simple une caméra hd à
l'arrière une petite caméra devant une
prise pour brancher un micro jack ses
compacts ces pratiques et j'utilise mon
iphone dans beaucoup de cas ça c'est
l'appareil numéro un mais en caméra
principale qui est quelque chose de
beaucoup plus sympa dj hi oslo plus
c'est une caméra qui est extraordinaire
d'ailleurs chez en train de filmer tout
de suite avec donc je vais vous la
montrer dans quelques instants quand je
vais utiliser une autre caméra
cette caméra là l extraordinaire
pourquoi parce que tout d'abord elle a
une fonctionnalité steadicam vous avez
une super stabilité vous pouvez la pause
et soit sur pied comme elle tout de
suite actuellement même si vous ne voyez
pas vous pouvez sinon si vous voulez la
gardait la main mais ça c'est la caméra
de vlog de l'avenir y a rien à dire
c'est vraiment extraordinaire c'est up
compact mobile ça passe partout ça se
mange y parvient c'est juste génial côté
micro vidéo micro de rhodes
le son est toujours top ce que je
reproche à ce micro lâché rhodes
c'est qu'il faut pas être trop loin si
vous êtes loin vous avez tout de suite
le son de la pièce se sera pas le micro
si vous voulez un peu plus de distance
la dot micro chine roth qui seront plus
performants pas celui là par contre pour
faire du blog avec une distance de
maximum je dirais un maître un mètre
cinquante pas plus c'est vraiment top
pour faire tenir le ce mot vous avez le
tripode et ce qu'ils appellent
l'extinction drogue ça vous permet tout
simplement de le faire tenir sur un pied
c'est en gros le pied gauche ou moins ni
plus ni moins et ça ça me permet de
l'attacher à la bécane quand je pars
faire un tour de moto
j'attache directement le sommet au
dessus comme ça ça me permet de faire
différents plans c'est vraiment sympa
après pour le montage j'ai besoin de
lunettes sinon j'ai les yeux défoncé un
bon vieux casque pour tout entendre
sinon c'est la merde
sony fait des super kf car ça c'est le
ndr 75,06 un casque qui appuient 15 ans
mais que j'adore toujours utilisée est
pour les montages un bon vieux mac et
côté lumière j'utilise un petit
éclairage manfrotto ça c'est aussi très
pratique
compact ça ouvre pas énormément il faut
pas de grandes distances v3 puissance de
l'aide ça c'est mon matos pour filmer
vous avez le smau qui est posée
directement sur le pied l'iphone qui me
sert de moniteurs et le micro qui sert à
enregistrer ça c'est la config de base
pour tous les plans mobile tous les
plans embarqué où je vais me retrouver
dans des endroits où je donne un petit
peu plus de discrétion
j'utilise mon iphone donc je prends à la
main le micro en dessous et je filme ça
me permet effectivement d'avoir quand
même une vraie stabilité alors je vais
avoir plus de secousses ce sera beaucoup
moins stable que si j'utilisais l'osm au
jeu vous montrer la différence confère
des travellings par contre c'est
vraiment très pratique
donc là tout de suite chez en train de
filmer avec l'iphone et avec le sou j'ai
les deux plans ça ne parle et voilà vous
voyez les différences entre un plan fixe
et un plan qui bouge directement là
dessus sur l'iphone côté mobilité
l'osmose c'est vraiment génial ça me
permet de me balader de faire des
travellings c'est vraiment la caméra qui
ne bouge pas je peux la montée et la bc
je garde toujours quelque chose d'hyper
stabiliser bon là je peux me déplacer et
franchement l'image reste stable c'est
vraiment ça qui est sympa c'est un vrai
steadicam c'est tout l'intérêt de ce
produit je peux l'utiliser pour faire
des travellings et plein d'autres choses
ce qui est génial e siècle se produit
c'est l'interface vous connecter
directement votre ce moment là vous
voyez tout de suite sur l'interface ça
c'est le sonos qui en rade régime est
actuellement l'eau ce mot qui est sur
son pied et vous avez juste à côté
directement l'ipad ou un iphone ou ce
que vous voulez qui me sert le moniteur
quand je suis sur mon iphone sur mon
ipad
ce qui est super c'est à dire qu'à
toucher l'écran et ça fait bouger la
caméra donc je choisis mes plans je
choisis ce que je veux faire je choisis
là où je veux aller ça c'est génial
vous pouvez choisir différents modes
vous avez des modes d'alsace vous pouvez
vous m forcément en vidéo ou directement
dessus vous choisissez votre résolution
peut filmer jusqu'en quatre cas là vous
avez sur le sommet un joystick vous
mettez dans le bas ça descend vers le
haut se montrent la droite la gauche les
deux coups joystick derrière parce que
vous le voyez pas mais vous avez un
petit joystick ici et hormel trois coups
joystick et on repasse en autres selphy
et le smur revient devant donc ça reste
vraiment un produit hyper compact hyper
pratique hyper sympa à utiliser où on
peut faire plein de choses en réalité
donc le sou mais ça reste un excellent
produit
vous avez énormément de possibilités
c'est un steadicam vous avez une
stabilité pour les selphy en marchant
c'est génial c'est vraiment l'outil
indispensable pour pouvoir faire du vélo
n'est d'autant plus que vous avez un
zoom optique et un zoom numérique et ça
c'est vraiment super intéressant il ya
juste une chose sur laquelle il faut
faire attention
moi j'ai pas pris l'eau ce mot j'ai pris
l'eau ce mot de plus l'osm au plus de
goûter quoi 100 euros une petite
centaine d'euros en plus
de l'eau ce mot par contre avec un os ce
mot doit avoir un minimum à mettre 50
entre vous et la caméra tandis qu avec
l'osm plus il vous faut au minimum 50 cm
donc pour toutes les scènes fille que
vous allez faire à bout de bras les 50
cm vous les avez avec l'osm en vous les
aurez pas ce qui fait que vous aurez
toujours un point les gens m'en fous sur
vous mais c'est en cinq lots souris
problématique
par contre l'osm opus est extraordinaire
pour ça vous insérez une petite carte
mémoire
vous ne voyez pas mais juste ici une
micro sd et ça marche
et pour le montage utilise final cut pro
qui pour moi reste une super solution un
logiciel qui est vraiment facile
d'utilisation qui épargnent heureux et
avec lequel on peut faire quasiment tout
ce qu'on veut
oh
[Musique]